what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
then I'm John Humphrey it's a good
Monday look about 550 to discover this
Avengers endgame clip dropped on Good
Morning America what are the odds anyhow
let's just hop right into it that was
the cinema town footage that lights are
gonna fly by
[Music]
so they're gonna use the stones this is
what I gathered from this clue it sounds
like a technology right up front use the
stones get it back I can't believe
they're showing us the last 20 minutes
of this movie this is literally like
right at the end so frustrating that
they do this Oh spoiler warning America
these guys listen before we go into
talking about this I wanted to say thank
you to everyone who's been downloading
and follow us on the Stardust app over
there with you 30 second reaction
reviews for any film TV show and/or
trailer also sometimes we do micro
sketches over there but you can also
post your reactions as well the whole
thing is totally free to download and
use we post daily so do it today so they
have this moment here at the very top of
it when I was on Collider movie talk
they talked about some of the footage of
the show at CinemaCon and this is
clearly that clip I think there was
something even more at the end of
whatever they showed at CinemaCon I
don't exactly know how they know he's
using the you know it starts off as
saying he used the stones again how the
heck did were they able to determine
that or predict are they watching him
teleport around or something like that
they have some kind of space-age
technology that can sense like the
presence of the usage of each different
energy that each different stone
represents or something I wouldn't put
it past them to have some kind of weird
device or some kind of weird means of
tracking that activity but they set that
up at Infinity Ward do you guys know
about that they set up something where
they're able to track it or does it just
start off where they've been able to
actually find his location in some
capacity this is obviously so early on
in the movie itself that light of you
know we'd be going in short-handed which
you do see in the trailer and somehow
theorized that that's in reference to
Bruce Banner
not being able to morph into the Hulk
still but he's still having that issue
so this is a moment you got Captain
Marvel who's pretty much the
motivational leading energy right now
because it doesn't say where she was at
during the time of the snap whatever
planet she was at so perhaps wherever
she was - that she saw some people
decimate away I was glad she must have
been right because the whole universe
you know you know it seems like in this
room is full of a lot of doubt at this
moment but he got Captain Marvel who's
just like let's just go do it let's go
handle business we get Thanos I'm like
how Captain America is also there the
two caps really yeah that's good yeah
let's go do it that sounds like the
plans go handle some business right now
plan and I kind of like the
self-awareness of what rody was doing
there like we're all about the superhero
game but we're also human we're very
traumatized by the situation I don't
lose more people lost my legs before I
also like that little hint it
Captain Marvel gives that her other
adventures other planets in the universe
that we're never gonna see get past all
those adventures and then just go right
into Captain Marvel Winter Soldier will
see one maybe Captain Marvel part two
will take place in like 2002 and we can
do an early 2000s throwback Nate I
actually like Captain Marvel in this
clip I do
I was I was curious to see how she'd
interact with the Avengers I heard about
that line at a cinema con that was like
one of the quotes of what she says there
because you didn't have me you know it's
a very cliche corny action line course
and it kind of reminds you of old
thoughts that's why I like how this ends
on this particular note with her Thor
cuz Thor just quiet the whole time in
the room yeah man just eatin bread rolls
in the back well everyone is like
debating there's like some people are on
her side about the situation others are
against her about the situation kind of
setback from all the tension for a lot
of it she's a new girl team but I like
how Thor just goes off her for body
language yeah mannerisms you know like
reason we've seen that clip in the
trailer
watching a plant in the scene where
everyone just comes in like alright now
Maya here's my version of interrogating
her finally it's just yeah after this
one little physical moment that they
share together I mentioned this on movie
talk and
the impression that I'm just getting is
they're gonna be going after nanos
obviously very early on in this movie
the Captain Marvel is probably gonna get
her ass handed to her you know and know
that's a very at this moment in time
she's a very sort of overconfident
character one thing that I think a lot
of people thought with the Captain
Marvel movie that was a bit of an issue
or some people thought it was a strong
issue was that she didn't really have
any major physical obstacles to overcome
that she's undefeated or fully abs is so
proficient at what she does that yeah at
a certain point just like oh you just
needed to unlock this corner of your
mind and you'll be fine so yeah to see
her go up against somebody or it's like
Oh even all your power isn't just the
easy answer to this question you know
it's like yeah she's probably going to
have to learn to outsmart Thanos as well
as just overpower him or something or
also learn to work as part of the team
because you know she's gonna have to do
both I think she's gonna be in in her
ass hand to her and the first fight
which I think would be great after the
events of Captain Marvel that we
witnessed swear it was pretty much you
know pretty simple work and that feels
natural because this feels like the next
step of jumping her into the universe is
like oK we've seen her on a very solo
outing now we need to see her with
everybody and we need to see how she
learns to become a part of the team you
know and every Avengers has some kind of
aspect of that you know it well I mean I
think that's why I think if this line
that she has here of before you didn't
have me even though this is all
theoretical it just seems like this is
how it's gonna go down
that she will get her ass kicked the
first time I would have an issue with
that line if it was like before he
didn't have me that she shows up at she
just beat that would be really be very
lackluster but this is so early on
clearly there you know she's gonna not
succeed in like yay let's go get him and
that's why I think that line is totally
fine was she being sarcastic about the
rest of the you know like the other
planets didn't have you guys I couldn't
tell that was a sincere line or as are
gassing
I thought it was sincere because it was
like yeah like that's why I've been gone
cuz I've been taking care of the
business that they need superheroes for
and they don't have them for you know is
what I got from that line so she
hopefully what was she like checking it
with fury
hey we got a god we've got a guy who
pokes out we've got a really old dude
who's buff his head she's like Avenger
dents that was the day we might that's
pretty that's pretty neat so when I get
back I can leave the team I wish you'd
come at the time I wish you told me when
you did it's been years it's weird
spoilers I love people do that spoiler
after we spoiled boy yeah we're not
pissed go back and skip it
I imagine that she's gonna have uh she's
gonna go from overconfident to being
humbled and the team player then she'll
come back to being confident at the end
everyone will make a joke and you know
and then later on after they after they
lose its and then imagine a man's gonna
show up come out of the corner over that
a find that footage or he comes out of
the quantum realm or you know whatever
they go into that part of the story what
they've confirmed is they're actually
going with that meme where ant-man
climbs up Thanos his bum and just
expands now you know they're really
upset that people figure that out
they're trying to you know push us off
the scent anyway guys listen for a wrap
this up I want to give it patron the day
shots a man named evgeniy Corona Corona
Corona rapper now Jenny III I would call
him I call him Eugene Levy Eugene Levy
Jenny Corona this guy lives in a tiny
tiny tiny part of a land somewhere in
some Island but he has an internet
service which is really cool yeah the
multiple very tribal warrior like but
he's the only one who discovered modern
day technology and decided to start up a
reaction channel which is a wonderful
reaction channel I actually watched his
Avengers and game reaction was as great
a saw his trying to laugh challenge and
if you laugh you have to do push-ups a
man that he hit
work out in there and he said to me
recently how can I make a giveaway
interesting during a live stream because
I'm actually doing one with Avengers and
game tickets tell you how you make it
interesting for everyone who came to
this video it made it this far in this
real rejects video go to his channel and
then find out how you can be a part of
the live stream by asking him directly
yeah please get some Avengers and game
tickets yeah provided that you caught
this video at the right moment in time
to where he hasn't done that livestream
just yet but it's soon it's complicated
but that's how it works figure it out
and get some tickets and fly out to
multiple alright guys well thanks for
tuning in did you like this Captain
Marvel clip I mean Avengers endgame
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell we'll check you guys
out on the afterlife and then I'm going
to go take a nap